please welcome if you care to come into  my living room then we can see what is  like  the picture of the Mona Lisa I bought  this in Rome  what I like about her is that sort of  half smile and her pose with your arms  sort of folded one and the other  well one of my hobbies is record  collecting and listen to music this was  recorded in Paris many years ago dear  since died these were done in London  when I attended an invitation to  Buckingham Palace to receive an award  this award was given to me for my  service agriculture in Granada and this  one is my wife and cousin this one is my  wife and children and this is myself  yeah this is myself and my wife didn't  outside the palace  after receiving award this award is  commander of the British Empire it was  quite an experience you know to visit  the palace and to shake the hand of the  Queen so thank you very kindly and enjoy  the rest of his stay in Grenada good bye  you